Speaker 1: All right. Let's speak next to
Paul from see it says see you. You what
is. See you, Paul. Is that a university?
Speaker 2: I know it's a it's
my airport, so I need, you know,
the three letters that they give you clear
Speaker 1: at which airport, which airport is this
Speaker 2: she on Mexico.
Speaker 1: Mexico. Oh, Chihuahua, Mexico. OK,
very good. All right. Well, what's going on?
Speaker 2: Paul on. I missed the call the other
day. I was in this school musical. Well,
I'm glad you're back. And I don't know,
I mean, if I had a specific question, it would
be like my mom got vaccinated in the US. OK,
she's over there right now. Then she took
a flight to two weeks ago, three weeks ago.
She has her vaccination card and all that and all
that stuff, but they may still require covid test.
She thought once she was vaccinated the
end of the airport, she will be asked to.
To show her vaccination card, hold on
Speaker 1: a second, let me back up
can we back up one second, Paul? Yeah, so,
yeah, when she came to the United States,
she was not yet vaccinated, is that correct?
Speaker 2: And oh, OK, OK, yeah, she she went to
New Zealand twice, she was she went in
like March or April, something like that.
She got vaccinated. She got back. She went back.
Speaker 1: OK, I got it. Yeah. The US requires
a negative test to come in. This is for Americans
and foreigners. I just came back from Spain. I'm
vaccinated. I needed a negative test to come to
the US. So that applies to everybody right now.
Speaker 2: And it's crazy because I can go to
us and get vaccinated and. And I got thinking
about these, like when when they when they
when talking about a fake vaccination card.
You coveted Tucker Carlson, talk about it.
Yeah, do you think it's affecting the numbers
now that the false vaccination cards and now
foreigners going there to get vaccinated?
I do think that folks like. The sharks.
How many Americans have to be vaccinated?
Speaker 1: I think it throws it off slightly,
but I don't think it's enough of it to make
any significant difference. You have to
remember, every one percent of the U.S.
is three point three million people. So half a
percent is one point sixty five million people
and a quarter of a percent represents 800000
people. So the number of people that would have to
do it to really make any substantive difference
is is huge. So you're right, on some level it
throws it off. But I think we have a pretty good
sense of how many Americans have been vaccinated.
Speaker 2: I just have one
last question, if I can. Sure.
Oh, I like it if they pass an infrastructure
plan and it goes through these red areas when
people don't want to leave the work they do
for the coal company or fracking company or
something like that to go join the green energy.
Do you think the EU and the U.S. will be open to.
To hiring foreign foreign people,
Speaker 1: oh, you're saying if in
red states, like a lot of the people don't want
to go and get jobs for green energy, will then
will the companies look to foreign workers?
Speaker 2: Yeah. You think you can
get a work visa?
Speaker 1: Oh, that's an you would have
to talk to an immigrant. I have no idea. But I can
tell you for sure that if companies have trouble
finding people, they will go wherever they need
to in order to find people to do work that's free.
Speaker 2: They're going to find a system with
people not wanting the good paying job. No, no.
Speaker 1: Actually, I think 99 percent of these
right wingers who love oil, if the job opportunity
is to be a solar panel installer and it pays
twenty five bucks an hour, I think they're going
to go and get the job. I think it's that simple.
Speaker 2: Well, actually, I think. Well,
thank you, David.
Speaker 1: OK, thanks,
Paul. Great to hear from
you, Paul, from Chihuahua,
Mexico. That does it for calls today.
I'll speak to everybody again very
soon. All right, let's get right into your emails.
You can email us info at David Pakman Dotcom.